when you go to start a business or you
pitch your services as a freelancer you
need to understand that the person
you're talking to
thinks about money totally differently
than you do right like now that I have
made some money the way I look at money
is totally different you know and I make
decisions not on oh how much does it
cost I make decisions around well how
much time is that going to save me you
know or a really great one is you know
when I was broke I would look at like a
five thousand dollar a month Service as
oh that's so expensive you know but then
as soon as you have a business a
business that's doing a million two
million three million four million right
you start looking at the 5K a month as a
negligible expense and you don't realize
that when you're starting out yeah right
because to when when you're living in
the rundown apartment you're like 5K a
month is a lot who would spend that
right and same thing with now
restaurants it's like I noticed that my
default if I'm in a new city and I'm
looking for a restaurant what's the
first thing that I do I pull up Google
and I sort by most expensive right
because there's a there's like a a bias
of well if it's more expensive it's
probably better right so if you're
pitching your services and you're
pitching them at a discount the person
that you're trying to sell to is like
I don't want the Honda Accord I want the
Ferrari right so it's it's all these
very interesting ways of thinking about
money that I it takes a while to see it
from the other side
yeah yeah I think one of the one of the
ways that I often think is like these
days is just in terms of uh sort of very
back of the envelope Roi calculations
like
I I booked a flight last night
um I'm going to Pakistan in the new year
for a cousin's wedding and the economy
class flight was 200 pounds and the
business class flight was 3 000 pounds
but doing the business class flight
would allow me to leave a kind of team
annual planning thing an extra two hours
later and I was like 100 valuable
because me being there with a team of 13
people or for to give two hours more
input on vision and direction of the
business is worth way more than 2 800
pounds hell yes that's a great example
that's something I just would not would
not be even able to Fathom had I not
were I not running a business because
it's like why the hell would anyone
spend 3K on a flight well you could
spend 200 quid for exactly the same
thing totally it's like you know the
value of money is just completely
completely changes yeah where are you
staying do you have access to Internet
or not does that allow you to work yes
or no you know can you make use of your
time by meeting someone else there
there's so many other things that have
to do with the decision than just the
price tag the price tags often like the
easiest part that's not what people get
caught up on it's how much every every
single ghost writing client that I had
it wasn't the price they would ask me
how much time is this going to consume
of mine yeah so if I pay you three grand
a month four grand five grand a month do
you need an hour of my time or do you
need 20 hours of my time that is the
decision it's not the amount of money
and again that takes that's really hard
to wrap your head around when you're
especially when you're first starting
out yeah and you're trying to charge for
things like you you can't understand
that decision
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye